how blue this is my background is pretty
blue - OH
joke about me being sad on the inside hi
guys my name is grace Helbig if you did
not know now you know your life is
different now I'm wearing orange
lipstick because I desperately want you
to like me I mean because it's Halloween
season it's the motion sexiest yes
Halloween is the celebration of just a
long con to wear a bikini out on the
town and go for it if that's what you
want to do but some people don't want to
go the sexier out for their Halloween
costume and I got your back
every year for the last two years I make
a video taking one common household item
or something that you could attain very
easily for very cheap and I show you how
you can make a variety of costumes using
that one item first year was a box
second year it was a paper bag this year
it's a bed sheet my thoughts what
couldn't believe that I was using a bed
sheet this year so you're just a few
costumes you can make using a bed sheet
oh I'm going to the wind
oh hello open to my show and we'll be
talking about no chumps campaign staff
do they have any souls there you go
there are my unsexy bed sheet Halloween
costumes for this year let me know if
you guys came up with any others using a
bed sheet I'd love to know if you like
this video click thumbs up that's a very
very direct way for me to know if you
appreciated any of this and subscribe to
this youtube channel because it doesn't
stop being stupid maybe that's something
you're into I don't know I've so long as
well ciao oh now it was silent